a decade ago this tiny Fox was on the
brink of extinction got a mama here kiss
your teeth please
for years scientists like Christina
bozer have been working to restore the
endangered island fox it lives only here
on Santa Cruz and the other Channel
Islands off the coast of Southern
California good Aylin foxes are smaller
than your average gray fox the fact that
they're isolated on these islands gives
them a unique personality they're very
curious now the Fox is back mama you
want to go it's coming off the
endangered species list you go find us
pups it's an exceptional success to be
able to take a species off the
endangered species list
particularly the Fox it's the fastest
mammal recovery in the history of the
Endangered Species Act that incredible
achievement wasn't easy or cheap you see
in order for the island fox to survive
scientists had it's been millions
restructuring an ecosystem in chaos
Santa Cruz Island is a very special
place
it's the most biodiverse island in the
California islands it has a great
history of human use as well as a number
of really special species that have
persisted on this island for thousands
of years humans have used the island for
ranching military operations and
recreation bringing new species into a
fragile ecosystem the biggest threat for
the foxes feral pigs that were tearing
the island apart these were pigs that
had been brought over by ranchers around
the 1850 or so and they attracted golden
eagles which were a non-native predator
and this Golden Eagle population grew to
the point that it was taking not just
pigs but also consuming baby foxes
unable to cope with the Golden Eagles
the population crashed a fewer than 100
foxes it's pretty clear what we had to
do to try to save the island Fox get rid
of the feral pigs all of them that task
fell on a new zealand-based crew of
hunters which killed over 5,000 swine
conservationists captured the Golden
Eagles and sent them back to the
mainland the remaining foxes went into a
captive
program amazingly it worked the fox
populations soared decade later from
that last golden eagle capture we're
seeing over 2000 foxes on santa cruz
island but it's a tenuous recovery the
fox may be back but it's still extremely
vulnerable you're obligated to keep a
pulse on the population for at least 5
years after the foxes are delisted this
means that we'll continue to figure out
how many foxes are out in the wild we'll
also keep track on their survival rate
and we'll also make sure that we're vac
setting these foxes because currently
the biggest threat to this population is
introduced diseases from the mainland
and that's how you say they tiny fox and
the age of mass extinction you know
they're yeah do you want it going